a new type of Animation this is
something that visually hasn't been seen
before Kid Cudi brings his musical
Vision to life with the help of some of
his best friends in the entertainment
industry there are some major names
Behind these characters recognize any of
their voices when you get this level of
people together magic happens number one
a passion project over three years in
the making Kid Cudi his real name Scott
mascotti who is most notably known for
his music was very particular about the
design of the characters I was like I
don't want this to be like a regular
animated show where the characters are
wearing the same thing every episode
something else worth noting is that the
film coincides with Kid Cudi's
Intergalactic album he planned to drop
with the animated special both were
released on September 30th 2022. the
music element was always a part of it in
the first place and this was more so how
can I bring the visual and the music and
marry the two and it'd just be the
perfect thing and not like what we've
seen before like a Visual Album
number two one of jabari's best friends
Ty Dolla Sign and Timmy just looked like
they would be two mile homies we would
just all kick it when Kid Cudi was
trying to figure out who he was going to
reach out to to be part of this it was
most likely just from his own intuition
because of this the production is filled
with lots of his really good friends
Timothy I was just like oh man it would
be funny if he was like my weed dealer
they met when Timothy was 17 and at one
of concuddy's shows they've been friends
ever since Cuddy thinks of him like a
little brother and to this day Timothy
considers him one of the big reasons why
he continued to pursue his acting career
his activity says I'm responsible for
his acting career and I'll just be like
you crazy if you're a crazy mother
saying that number three the voice
behind Meadow's pregnant friend Karina
throughout Intergalactic Karina
continues to caution and encourage
Meadow about her ongoing romance with
Jabari Vanessa Hudgins is a seasoned
actor dating all the way back to her
early childhood she's well known for her
starring role as Gabriella in the High
School Musical trilogy but continues to
shine through the screen in roles from
films like bad boys for life and Tick
Tick boom she hasn't done a lot of voice
acting but it's no less than second
nature to her considering her wide range
of talent when it comes to Intergalactic
she's very passionate about Kid Cudi's
music behind the project and to see how
that was developed into the
intergalactic I was like that is the
coolest coolest thing ever Number Four
Jessica Williams plays jabari's neighbor
and love interest Meadow did you know
that the characters were based on the
people who voiced them when I saw
Jessica's face I felt like I was looking
at Meadow Jessica Williams hosts the
podcast two dope Queens portrays Lally
Hicks and the Fantastic Beasts series
and stars in many other well-known
projects bringing characters to life
definitely comes naturally to her so
naturally that they even Incorporated
her personal makeup look into
intergalactic's Meadow I've been a fan
of wearing black eyeliner and then just
a little bit of blue on the top since
high school I really appreciate that the
animators took the time to study my face
that was actually a very personal thing
that made it into this gigantic project
number five his very first voice acting
credit aside from being in two episodes
of HBO's insecure Ty Dolla Sign
typically sticks to music he has a verse
on Fifth Harmony's 2016 hit work from
home and some of his own tracks you
might recognize are Orna and blase he's
also an extremely talented writer he was
involved in Rihanna's four or five
seconds in Intergalactic he voices one
of jabari's best friends Kai look man I
just don't want you to end up in a
friend zone watering her house plants
and feeding her cat you can also catch
him in one of Kid Cudi's Intergalactic
songs willing to trust that's also
featured in the film that was one of
three songs I played in the pitch
meeting and it's pretty much the song
that sold the show number six another
one new to the scene of Animation Laura
Harrier is an actor and model known for
her role in Spider-Man homecoming and
Spider-Man far from home in
Intergalactic she plays Carmen jabari's
ex Kid Cudi describes her character and
exes in general as a test from the
universe sent down once you meet someone
else though this is one of Laura's first
steps into animation she viewed it as
more of a live action piece like I fully
was so immersed in the world
you want to be friends now I mean we
could try number seven
intergalactics Jordan the BMX Superstar
so you go sir
um yeah Jaden Smith is like a little
brother to Kid Cudi so it's only natural
that he'd voiced a character alongside
him in Intergalactic people like Timothy
The Eagles I had you know that
relationship Dynamic even plays a role
in their on-screen characters
wait a minute you need to go actually
break up with this girl man number eight
it's pretty hard not to know this guy it
ain't true love unless the police are
involved Macaulay Culkin will always
have a special place in our hearts as
the mischievous Kevin McAllister from
Home Alone considering he doesn't tend
to pursue acting anymore it was a real
treat to hear his voice as the hilarious
downtown Pat in Intergalactic Culkin
continues to do projects that naturally
come up for him like his good friend
Seth Green's movie changeland and he
continues to work on his comedy site
bunny ears.com number nine another
talented musician behind one of these
voices I went to school right up the
street from here
who would have thought I'd be here a
couple years later 070 Shake whose real
name is Danielle balbuena is a member of
the group 070. they released a mixtape
together titled the 070 project chapter
one she also released her debut EP
titled glitter in March of 2018. she
first started gaining recognition for
working with Kanye West on his music
productions in Wyoming he later ended up
signing her to his good music imprint
after being featured on Kanye West songs
like ghost towns and violent crimes she
released her own debut album in 2020
titled modus vivendi number 10. did
anyone watch Broad City or alter Latino
I met them yes Arturo Castro got his
start in the entertainment industry by
hosting his own show connection on
Guatemala's national network a year
before moving to New York City he is a
natural comedian best known for his role
as Ileana wexler's roommate Jamie on
Broad City he he also portrayed David
Rodriguez on the Netflix crime series
Narcos in Intergalactic he gets to play
jabari's overzealous Cosmic Comics
co-worker welcome to the Cosmic Family
my bro hmm
number 11. the voice of Reed The
Catalyst for Jabari and Meadows meet
cute nice to meet you Javari I'm Meadow
Reed also doesn't know how to read the
room yeah and I'm Reed Chris Abbott is
another actor on this list with a lot of
experience behind the camera but a lot
less than the voiceover Booth he's been
in several noteworthy films and TV
series like the Sleepwalker on the count
of three and Catch-22 number 12 a singer
songwriter dancer and actor tayanna
Taylor can do it all she brings to life
Intergalactic Stellar boxing coach it's
round 12. your man says wobbling he's
weak let's light him up jab jab a
jumpstart to her singing career started
in 2005 when she signed a record deal
with Pharrell Williams's Star Trek
entertainment she is also a well-known
and talented choreographer
choreographing the music video for
Beyonce's ring the alarm so how many of
these famous actors and musicians did
you recognize on your first watch
through of Kid Cudi's Intergalactic do
you think any of them should keep up
with voice over work let us know in the
comments who your favorite character was
[Music]